ah
Walter
what's our wastelanders welcome back to
this week's fallout 4 mod of the week
this week covering something a little
more docile something that can allow you
to build your very own home away from
home wherever you like wanna courage in
the Hills you got it
want a property on the beach go for it
want to set up shop in the middle of an
irradiated wasteland sounds a bit odd
for sure you do you this mod it's called
conquest by the mod of chesco and it
allows you to camp and build brand new
settlements anywhere in the wastelands
of Boston this mod comes fully equipped
with camping equipment allowing you to
settle down for the night recharge your
batteries save your game cook and get a
good night's sleep then you can either
pack up and head off on to your next
adventure or if you've come to love your
little campsite then you can expand on
it and create a fully fledged settlement
ad camp site you can build a fireplace a
pot for cooking scrap your equipment for
parts build 10 for the night play sport
with generators and all-in-all make your
night under the stars as comfortable as
possible to create a new little town you
just have to set down a workshop and
your new settlement will be made
available to expand currently you can
build a maximum of 10 new settlements
but for me that's more than enough
settle management for one wasteland oh
there are plenty of unique locations in
the game to create somewhere to keep
your power armor and for settlers to
live but the ability to create your new
home from scratch in any corner of the
wasteland you want makes a bit more
exciting it's almost like you're a
frontiersman scouring the lands for a
rich spot to settle and as a bonus this
mod should work with any other
settlement expansion mods additional
settlement items or the wasteland
workshop DLC if you've used this mod
then let us know what you think in the
comments section below
or even better download it build an
awesome settlement and share the
screenshots with us on twitter using the
hash tag GS fallout and make sure to
come back next week where we will be
covering more fallout for goodness and
until then I've been Dave and stay safe
out there wasteland OH